so have you got your numbers there do
you see them
okay now I'm not going to make you do it
now but later on I am going to ask you
in your books to replicate you've
already done row 203 you've done those
but where four or five we don't have
them in our books but you can clearly
see the same pattern right as we predict
it in this X to the four row all the
numbers are positive all the numbers are
positive okay and in fact you've got the
same number here that appears over on
the opposite side right when you've got
an odd power same deal but you've got
negatives on this side positive than
that time right one last thing before we
actually just look at the pictures okay
look at these numbers here when you go
down a column can you see that down a
column or down this column or down this
column what's happening for 16 64 256
etc what's happening it's getting bigger
and bigger and bigger do you remember
what we drew this thing right also this
one we went for among negative 32 30 do
you remember that you should have the
graph from yesterday right well if you
did the same for these guys your graphs
going to have to go real real high okay
so now in a browser why don't you go
ahead and open up to DES loss I've still
got yesterday's on here so we're going
to use this as our basis
okay so y equals x squared y equals x
cube we looked at these before so now if
I put on y equals x to the 4 and y
equals x to the 5 have a look at these
things okay now what I'm going to do is
let's put on the even ones first oh
maybe I'll put on one more y equals x to
the 6 we did a new color that's was it
that yeah okay great thank you
when it was both of yours like hmm I had
a biggest is attended
okay so can we have a look at this yes
then hopefully you're getting on to DES
well so you can do this yourself what I
want you to notice is that as soon as ya
desmos calm if you haven't been ever
recently this is what we just did in
numbers in fact I'm even going to put
the numbers there let's put the numbers
across okay so these numbers correspond
to these pictures all right let me say
that again these numbers correspond to
these pictures all I've drawn is the
even powers do you notice how everything
is positive absolutely everything it's
all above the x-axis everything going up
and that corresponds to the fact that
for these even powers the numbers are
all positive no negative signs inside
okay however do notice what's going on
here can you zoom in if you started to
draw these what's going on down here
okay so yeah it's interesting
X to the 4 and X to the sixth they're
like filling out at the bottom it's like
x squared put on a bit too much weight
and it's kind of like rounded at the
bottom here and if you keep on going if
we go ahead and put some really crazy
power of X ya put in something big y
equals
sure look at x2 100 that looks weird
right now I hope you actually knows yeah
it's um it looks square or rectangular
but really what it is is it's kind of
like a parabola in it's got the symmetry
it's still curved it doesn't look very
curved but if you zoom in far enough you
can see the curve is there right the
curve is unmistakable it's just a
different scale okay in exactly the same
way if you have a look at the even sorry
the odd powers let's do those three five
seven you can if you have a look I'm
just concentrating on the odd powers
right now as Jake was suggesting they
kind of all do look like the cubic graph
that's the green one except this one is
like more extreme versions right there
more extreme versions so you can see how
they go higher and higher but they're
also flatter and flatter if you zoom in
just like it looked like it was getting
really square go in ahead and put in
extra power 101 what's it going to look
like
there we go